Today, with reinforcement learning, this
is where things are going to start
getting interesting because we will be
moving from
um
from a world where someone tells us what
to do with imitation learning to
uh to a world where the agents interact
uh themselves to figure out exactly uh
how to learn uh policies through trial
and error.
Um so, uh to recap where we left off in
imitation learning, we had an expert
give us demonstrations, uh some data set
with state action trajectories, and our
goal was to uh to find and learn a
policy uh that mimics or copies this
expert. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> And so, we we had this example with
self-driving cars uh where, you know,
like we observe the road, we pass it
through our policy, uh and then we get
like some steering decision, for
example. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> but the fundamental question uh or
limitation here is that uh we are
entirely dependent on the expert, on the
quality of the demonstrations
uh that the expert provides, and um
imitation learning fundamentally doesn't
have a notion of being better than the
expert.
Uh so, like we can never become better
than this uh expert uh trajectory data
set that um some unknown expert
collected.
And so, this is essentially the ceiling
we're we'll try uh we're trying to break
today uh with reinforcement learning.
Um before we get into this, um kind of
like a quick recap um for the uh MDP
formulation, the Markov decision problem
um since this is what um RL essentially
uh builds upon. So, we have again this
uh uh state space, um the action space,
uh transition dynamics, and a reward
function. And uh this essentially uh
loops this uh um environment uh agent
interaction. So, the robot observes some
state
and then it selects We will do questions
later, sorry.
Selects an action and then we will get a
transition together with the reward of
this.
Um
We also defined what we are that we are
that we are optimizing in MDPs.
Is not working?
Oh.
Again?
Can you hear me now? Is this better?
Sorry, what?
Can you hear me better?
Okay, perfect.
All right, thanks for the tip.
Um
So,
yeah, so we mentioned the accumulated
return is the reward the agent receives.
Um we
Sorry.
Trying to get this.
All right. Um
and our RL objective is the expected
return under the trajectory distribution
induced by our policy.
And so, the optimal policy is the arc
max of of J
over here.
>> [clears throat]
>> And so,
um last time we didn't fully answer like
how are we actually computing now this
this policy and that's what kind of the
agenda is for today.
Um maybe before we start talking about
RL algorithms, I guess like kind of like
a funny question, um
so if imagine you want to train this RL
algorithm and we have this this toy
example, right? Where we are driving uh
the mountains on this narrow road
um and we have let's say a reward of
plus one for for staying on the road and
a reward of minus one for the car uh
falling off the cliff, right?
And now, in principle, there appears to
be um some sort of like discontinuity
here in this uh
uh between staying and falling on the
road, right? And if we try to directly
optimize this reward function,
um
>> [clears throat]
>> let's say it will with with like the the
state of the car or something,
um then we can't really uh solve this
directly with with like our favorite
gradient descent solver because uh it's
not a it's a non-smooth function, right?
So, it's not continuous and it's not
differentiable.
And um
as you can see here, it's like
essentially like a Heaviside step
function.
Uh and so, the gradient is essentially
uh zero everywhere except um um so, you
don't get any learning signal for this
uh except at the boundary where it where
you jump like from minus one to to plus
one where it's undefined.
And um
so, why can we like kind of still kind
of learn these behaviors even if this
uh reward function is like not
differentiable, right? And so,
ultimately in in RL, like um it's all
about uh maximizing expectations. Um
so, uh in principle, we often talk about
like, you know, actions that get high
rewards
uh in um you know, like discrete actions
or so, but um we are typically
interested in um optimizing the expected
value of those rewards. And here, the
kind of the magic lies in in the fact
that um the expected values uh can be
perfectly continuous in the parameter
space um of their distributions
uh even if the underlying uh reward
function it's uh highly discontinuous.
Um and so, this allows us then to use um
uh smooth optimization methods like like
gradient descent uh to optimize these
objectives seemingly uh
non-differentiable such this like binary
uh rewards for the car driving example.
Um so
uh in in our case, if we model, let's
say the the event of falling
uh from the road kind of as a Bernoulli
variable,
um then um you know, the actual
although we will have this sharp
discontinuity, the expected value of
this uh reward with respect to our
policy parameters
will remain smooth.
Uh and here is kind of the visual
confirmation of everything I just said.
Um so, the the red line is is still kind
of the original reward function, the the
non-smooth heavy steps function with
zero graded gradients almost everywhere.
And then the the blue dashed line is the
expected expected value which is
effectively a convolution of the reward
function with the policy's density
function.
Um and so, kind of the the key maybe the
key
uh message here is that um
>> [clears throat]
>> marginalizing over a stochastic policy
uh turns a non-smooth reward function
into a smooth objective.
All right. So, we have now our
objective. Uh we have this expected
discounted return and we know now that
it's smooth in in policy parameters and
we can
now try to train on this. Great.
Um and we know that this is essentially
a scalar value that tells us how good
our policy will be on average starting
from the first [snorts] state.
All right. So, it summarizes the kind of
entire quality of your policy in
this one number.
Um but there is kind of like one kind of
practical issue when we try to do this,
that it's essentially
uh if you know, if you look at this
term, this means that we have to like
expand this and and unroll this to the
end of the whole trajectory
before we know how good we are doing,
right?
So on this kind of like you know, it's
maybe not ideal for the car because this
means
we would need to let the car fall down
the cliff before we actually learn that
this is like a bad thing to do. Um
and so this is essentially very slow and
um
kind of like could be catastrophic in
some cases, right? So
what can we do about this, right? Is
there a kind of a better way how we can
go around this, right? Can we estimate
this without unrolling each episode
until the the end?
Um and the answer is yes, we can do
this. And the key here is essentially
the the Markov property that we saw
during the NDP
lesson um
lecture that essentially
we can factor the whole trajectory
distribution
>> [clears throat]
>> without kind of like depending on on the
past to to predict the the future. Um so
this leads us directly to to value
functions, right?
So how in order to avoid unrolling the
the whole trajectory before getting like
this the signal of
>> [clears throat]
>> what is good and bad.
Um so
the value function is kind of similar as
the the the the J scalar from before.
It's again kind of like a single number
that summarizes
how good it is to be in a certain state,
but now it is
>> [clears throat]
>> essentially now it's conditioned on
on the state rather than average over
all the different starting states. So,
it's kind of like a local version
that says how good is my policy from
this specific state
onwards.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and
um
the key idea of why we can use this
value function is again
the Markov property
that
we can say that the whole future depends
only on the current state and not on the
full history.
Uh so, while essentially conditioning on
the current state is sufficient to to
summarize everything relevant about this
uh the past.
Um
And now essentially
um you can
I want to draw your attention to to the
last formula here that kind of explains
the relationship between those two
where the RL objective is essentially
the value function averaged over the
different
starting states.
Okay, so how do we compute this
efficiently?
Um the
the insight for this is is pretty uh
simple. So, any infinite sum
of rewards [clears throat] can be split
essentially uh into what we
get right now in terms of rewards and
then like a discounted version of what
we will be getting starting tomorrow.
And so
with this kind of like algebraic
algebraic manipulation,
we turn an infinite horizon problem into
a one-step recursive equation.
And this going back to our car example
means that
um
the value of being in a particular
position on the mountain road equals the
immediate reward I'm getting right now
at this one step
uh plus some gamma times the value of
wherever I will end up next.
And so, this means I don't need to
simulate the the full rest of my drive.
I just need to know how good
the next state is, and then the value
function handles everything essentially
beyond that.
Um so, and this is what we call also
like bootstrapping.
Uh so, we only need to do this kind of
one-step look ahead and then use our
current estimate of of V for for the
rest.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right. So, now we have a way to
evaluate how good a policy is.
Um the the value function we computed
via the Bellman equation. Um but
you know, ultimately we don't want to
just evaluate um
a policy. We want to find the best one,
right? We want to like improve like the
policy to find the the optimal one.
Um and so, the optimal value function is
simply the maximum value achievable from
state S over all possible
policies.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So, going back to the car example, the
value is the optimal value function is
the value of being at a particular
position on the mountain road when
driven by the best possible driver.
Um so, it's essentially the the the
um the best performance or ceiling any
policy could achieve from that state
onwards.
Um
and the optimal policy, on the other
hand, is the one that achieves the
ceiling
or optimal performance from every
starting state.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um and maybe like one
insight looking into this formulas to
make this tractable is that
once we have the the optimal value
function, we don't need to search over
all policies to act optimally. We can
just we just need like one greedy single
step look ahead.
So essentially [clears throat]
to summarize this,
the key inside is that this this optimal
value function compresses this infinite
horizon planning problem into a sequence
of one step greedy decisions.
So all the kind of long-term reasoning
or like anything
about what will happen many steps into
the future is implicitly encoded in this
value function. So once we have computed
this, we can like act optimally
>> [clears throat]
>> because it's like kind of like
local computation.
All right. So
how do we actually compute the optimal
value function in practice?
Um
like the first answer to this is
algorithm called value iteration which
is surprisingly simple. We we start by
initializing all values to zero assuming
every state is worth nothing.
>> [clears throat]
>> And then we repeatedly
apply the Bellman optimality update.
Once we convert, we extract the optimal
policy with one final greedy step.
And
like this is
essentially
there is a conversion proof that because
this is a contractor contraction
operation, it is bound to converge
>> [snorts]
>> because essentially
when you apply when you apply this to
two when the you apply the Bellman
operator to two different value
functions you make [clears throat] them
closer than before.
Um but maybe like more importantly like
let's look at the limitations, right? Uh
so one big limitation is that uh this
assumes that we have a known uh dynamics
model like a transition uh model
uh in advance. Um
so analytically, we all also need to
sweep through all the states. Uh so it's
quite heavy uh computationally, right?
So uh for every state and every action,
uh so which can become quite intractable
for larger uh
>> [clears throat]
>> state spaces. Um and in practice, like
we usually use like, you know, some
tabular representation for these
policies. So like the state space uh
should be like what discrete and like
quite small. Uh so we can like enumerate
it on a table.
Um
here is a small example I programmed or
I let Claude program for me. Not going
to lie.
Um
the [clears throat] setup is simple. The
green cell is the the goal with a reward
of plus one. Um
the red cell
um over there is is danger with minus
one. Then the gray cells are the walls.
And the agent is stochastic.
80% of the time uh it moves in the
intended direction. Uh 10% uh the other
[clears throat] times it drifts in in
the
either direction.
And so you can see here like, you know,
uh what we just discussed. You start
with with uh total ignorance.
Um and then um once you start applying
the the Bellman updates, uh the states
uh closer to the goal uh start updating.
Uh and you can see how it like kind of
back back propagates. Um
so you can see how the um like visually
the information flows through the state
backwards through the state state space
uh one step at a time.
Um, and then the arrows you see are like
kind of like the uh optimal um
actions for for each state. So, this is
like dynamic programming in its purest
form.
Um, no path planning.
No nothing hard-coded, just like
repeated local Bellman updates.
Okay.
So,
value iteration works
uh by taking the max uh over actions at
every step.
Um, but this implicitly assumes we're
acting optimally uh always, right? Um,
but maybe we want to also ask a simpler
question uh first um in terms of how
good is a specific policy that I already
have.
Um,
and [clears throat] so this is uh policy
uh
policy evaluation.
Um,
so it's um
it's very similar, if you look at this
uh to value iteration, except that uh we
replace the max with expectation under
the policy. So, instead of picking the
best action, we are averaging over
whatever uh our policy tells us to take.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> so
um on its own, policy evaluation like
doesn't improve anything, but it's kind
of like the first step we need uh
towards policy improvement
um because we you can't improve a policy
if you don't know how good it is. Um,
and so this is essentially um what we're
going to like look into next.
Maybe just to clarify again before we
move on to the policy iteration, um
I tried to put the both both operations
or updates side by side uh so because
it's easy to like uh conflate them,
uh and they look essentially identical,
but as I said, uh we um like uh
change the max for for like the
expectation here.
Um,
maybe like on on a side note, uh, also
because of this this change also affects
the complexity, because now we no
longer, um, maximize over, uh, all
actions since the policy is fixed. So,
now it's going to be like state space,
uh, squared.
All right. Uh, and now we we can put
these two things together um, for policy
iteration. So, this is kind of our first
way how we can improve, uh, our
policies.
Uh, so, um, we have our policy
evaluation to measure how good our
current policy is. Um, and then we have
a greedy policy improvement step, um,
from value iteration, uh, which tells us
how to do better, uh, given a value
function, right? And so, here we are
like essentially just alternating, uh,
between both of them. Um,
and, uh,
yeah, I here I just kind of I just put
the update rule for the policy
evaluation, but this is kind of in
reality a a loop until convergence. I
just didn't put it there. And, um,
>> [clears throat]
>> yeah, so, should be a pretty, uh,
self-explanatory.
And, um, this is also essentially, um,
guaranteed, um, to uh, to to converge.
Uh, because um, yeah, like the space of
deterministic policies in this case is
is is finite.
And so, each iteration should like
strictly, uh, improve the policy, um,
until we have reached the optimal
policy. So, in practice, um, it
converges pretty fast. Um, here is the
same grid world example. Um, and now you
can see, uh, that we have like these two
different phases between policy
evaluation and and and policy
improvement. Um and uh on the right
you'll see also the the return plot
um
which [clears throat] should always kind
of strictly go go up.
Um
uh because yeah, as I said before, like
every update should like strictly be
better.
Oops, sorry. Okay, so now we have a kind
of a
uh set of tools to um for computing
optimal policies, right? So, value
iteration uh and then policy iteration
or like with policy evaluation together.
And um they are um beautiful and have
like strong convergence guarantees.
Um but there is kind of like uh
uh a a strong kind of limitation that
makes them or at one of of many that
makes them difficult to apply for for uh
robotics or kind of more uh complex
problems. Um
And
um
>> [clears throat]
>> so
uh essentially the biggest one is that
we need to have a dynamics model at test
time, right? Um so, this means um that
um this expectation uh requires
marginalizing um the value function over
all uh transition uh distributions. And
so, for every candidate action we
consider at every time step during the
deployment on the real robot, we would
need to like kind of calculate all of
this. And so, this would take like very
very long time uh to compute all this
before actually executing an action. So,
for example, if we have like a
high-frequency robot like uh it might be
a little bit difficult. Right? And
besides um in robotics like it's often
difficult to assume that we have a
dynamics model
um because the world is messy and um
it's like sometimes hard to model.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and as I said before, like even if you
have a a model uh querying it at every
time step might be slow, especially if
you have like a 7° of freedom like
continuous action space for your
manipulator.
So you would need to evaluate infinitely
many candidate actions.
So and this is kind of the fundamental
motivation for Q functions. The key idea
is what if we could absorb the dynamics
model
into the value function itself during
training so that a test time we never
need to query this.
Right?
And so during training now the
expectation over
over P is um
computed and the result is is stored in
the
over the transition sorry over the
dynamics model is computed and then the
um
>> [clears throat]
>> the result is stored inside the Q
values.
Um so this Q SA already uh
essentially contains or is baked in the
answer to uh if I take the the action A
um here what's the best possible future
return average over all the
different ways that the environment
could could respond.
Um
so the [clears throat] trade-off that we
are making here with the Q functions is
that
it's slightly higher dimensional than
the value function, right? So now it's
not just conditional on the state but
also on the action. Um but and it might
be more difficult a bit to learn because
of that, but uh for uh model-free
robotics where we might not always have
um
access [clears throat] to a reliable
dynamics model
this is a price um typically worth
paying.
Um this is just to reiterate the big
benefit um if we actually do like Q
value iteration at test time um we um
don't have to query the dynamics model.
This is just a look-up um
uh or an argmax over a fixed function.
So we don't need to simulate uh forward
because the dynamics model is already
encoded in the Q function itself.
All right. So,
um
the Q func- the Q function eliminates
the need for the dynamics model at test
time, but there is still kind of the
problem that we needed um
uh for
uh during uh training time, right?
Um and as I said, like we might even not
always have access to the dynamics
model.
Um so, how can we get rid of it uh
entirely so we don't even need it during
training?
Um and so, Q-learning, this is
essentially where Q-learning comes for
from, uh and it has like a quite nice
answer. We can replace the expectation
uh over the dynamics model with a single
sample from the actual experience. Uh
so,
we can, you know, like
essentially query the environment and
kind of experience like uh what is
happening. So,
um
we can uh instead of calculate um an
average of all the possible uh future uh
states, we just kind of take an action,
uh observe a single sample, and um
uh store this transition.
And we can create essentially uh this
this TD target,
um
which [clears throat] is kind of like a
uh estimate an unbiased estimate of the
true Q val- value.
And so, um
we essentially now, with this learning
update, we can
um
notch our uh TD targets uh towards
um the the true uh Q functions um by
sampling from the environment.
Um treating essentially the world kind
of as its own simulator.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um
Here is Q-learning on the same uh grid
world.
And uh
maybe you'll you'll see um kind of a
a difference from the previous examples,
right? So, in the previous examples,
because we had this access to the
dynamics model, um uh
uh
like the policies would converge very
fast, right? Um
now we don't have any dynamics model,
and so we have to spend a a long time
kind of like exploring and querying the
uh like getting samples from the
environment um to figure out like what's
the best uh policy, right? And so, I I
speed this up like quite a bit more than
the previous uh demos uh to kind of show
you, but um this is for example one
trade-off we're making. Now, this is not
as sample efficient as the previous uh
algorithms that had access to a dynamics
model.
Okay.
So, we have Q-learning, um which is a
model-free uh algorithm that learns
purely from experience. Um
but maybe like I want to ask one
question that is kind of subtle, but
kind of uh interesting, right? Uh so, we
we know that it learns from experience,
but does it actually uh matter which
policy uh collects the experience we use
to update our Q-values?
Um so, think about this carefully. Like,
is there any dependency on like which
>> No, because here we try to act with
respect to the optimal policy, right?
So, it doesn't matter which
behavioral policy collected
>> Yes.
Exactly. So, as you very correctly said,
the the max operator is the key. Uh it
selects the best possible action at the
next state, regardless of which policy
generated uh this transition. Uh and so
this means Q-learning is off policy
uh and so the data uh that uh we use for
the updates can come from any behavior.
Uh it can be a random agent, an old
version of the policy, uh human
demonstrator, or any mixture of those.
Uh and that's what makes it also very
very powerful. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> the learning target always evaluates the
optimal action
uh independent of how the data was
collected.
Um
So, Q-learning is off policy because the
the max operator in the TD target uh
always evaluates the
optimal action, right?
Um
and um
here is also uh maybe like one variant
of this um for on-policy, which is uh
the SARSA algorithm,
where instead of answering with the max,
"What is the best I could do next?" uh
we ask, "What am I actually going to do
next?" Um
so, it learns the value of the policy um
it is currently executing, including all
of its exploratory uh mistakes.
Um
So, it's kind of like a very
subtle change, right? Like it's
essentially everything remains the same
except for for this operation where we
replace the max.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and so,
this has like profound implications in
the behavior um
that uh this will learn, this on-policy,
uh because
the SARSA value um for example, if you
have in the self-driving example like a
nervous driver, it will uh correctly
penalate penalize states where a nervous
uh driver is more likely to do uh
mistakes.
Um while Q-learning will ignore this.
Um let's compare both in this kind of
like classic uh example cliff walking
task, right? So, uh where both agents
start in the left and the goal is on the
right, and you know, there is like this
uh this kind of like uh death uh
uh cells, right? And so, you can see
that um the
uh Q-learning finds the optimal policy,
which is the shortest distance uh right
across the
the edge of this like death uh
uh cells, while the SARSA le- learns a
much more uh
safer policy, where it's like not
optimal, but it avoids going like on
this ledge, so it doesn't like risk
falling into one of these death uh
cells.
All right. So, this is kind of like uh
what we have seen so far, right? So, we
have covered some exact solution methods
uh like value iteration, policy
iteration, and Q-value iteration, uh
where um
you typically need uh dynamics model uh
but for sure for trading uh for testing,
you don't need to do it for Q-values,
and it's typically like for tabular
representations.
And then we have started looking into
some uh value based methods um
>> [clears throat]
>> where we start uh working uh with this
like model-free uh algorithms that that
learn from interactions. But, still kind
of like constrained, right? In in terms
of like okay, like very small state
space and on grid worlds.
Uh
maybe like not super
applicable for robotics just yet, right?
Um and so, now we kind of like think
about how we can scale some of these
things up, right? Um
especially for image observations,
right? Uh
if we want to um
maybe before we go all the way to to
robot arms uh like play like video games
like you know kind of Atari
even then if you want to have like an
image observation space this is like
really really big right it's like 256
pixels
and then sorry values and then like 84
by 84 um
pixels for the image and then usually
you need to like stack some frames so
you can kind of see also what is
happening before so it's very very large
and you cannot like store this it's
astronomically large you cannot store
this in kind of like a tabular fashion
right
and and so this brings us to kind of
like one of the um
one of the seminal papers that kind of
was a breakthrough in deep reinforcement
RL which is called DQN
probably many of you have already heard
of this so this is deep Q learning and
core idea is is conceptually quite
simple you know you take everything you
know about Q learning and replace the
table or the tabular representation
with a deep convolutional neural network
you input a stack of
raw game frames pixels
and then the output is like a vector of
Q values one per discrete action
and then you train it with your Q
learning updates and that's it
and why this is so so seminal is that
this is kind of this was the first time
where like single algorithm with the
same architecture and hyper parameters
was able to learn all 49 different like
Atari games directly from raw pixels
with with no like kind of like
handcrafting or game specific
engineers
also like as a side note
this was kind of the year I I I I moved
to Freiburg for to study
where Martin Riedmiller was a professor
and and he just
left to
to do his sabbatical at a at a small
startup called DeepMind.
Um
And
yeah, so that was like great times.
Um
Yeah, so
yeah, maybe I will skip this a little
bit for time,
but this is kind of the the main
algorithm we just covered.
Um I want to go over two key innovations
that they made in this paper to make
this work. Um the first one is the
experience replay buffer.
Um the idea is simple, instead of
discarding each transition after using
it only once,
they stored it in a replay buffer,
and then sampled mini batches from this
for training. Um
why was this important? Well, because
the it helps break temporal
correlations, right? If you remember the
whole IID thing in the in the first or
second lecture we covered,
right?
>> [clears throat]
>> If you know, you input it like
consecutive transitions from the same
trajectory,
then you know, this is bad for learning.
In in this way, they could break this
temporal correlation, and
how
half this samples look approximately
like
IID to the optimizer.
And then stabilizes the training.
And also
you can then like
uh
also replay of course like past
transitions several times, and maybe
like there are like some, you know,
interesting corner cases that then you
don't have to like relive, that you can
really forget.
Um the second challenge
here from using like deep networks for
Q-learning comes from the correlation
between the estimated value and the
target value for the estimation.
Um so concretely uh um
the
uh Bellman equation states that the the
current value um
>> [clears throat]
>> um the the current value uh depends on
the Q value of the next state
um and the current parameterization
parameterization of the network.
And uh so this means that um an update
for the for the current Q value will
like essentially alter the um also the
the values for the next state uh the
next Q state causing instability in
learning um and increase uh possibility
of divergence. How they solve this is um
the trick is pretty simple.
Um
uh they maintain a separate copy of the
uh network with the frozen parameters to
compute the target. Uh this is why they
call this delayed target network. So
typically the second target network is
updated either slowly via
uh averaging or periodically after a
number of fixed steps.
Um
here are the the results. Um
I think the most important one is not
just like the raw scores, but the
generality that I mentioned before that
it was kind of one the first algorithm
that could kind of like
uh out of the box without any hyper
parameter tuning
um
like achieve like uh
super uh very very good performance
uh uh in this 47 games.
Um
DQN works remarkably well, but it has
also kind of like a systematic failure
mode um
which is the overestimation bias. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so the the the idea or the insight here
is that like the Q values typically are
not perfect, they have noise and errors
and um the maximum of a set of noisy
estimates is usually greater or actually
always greater
or equal to the maximum of the true
values. And so, here the noise doesn't
like the noise doesn't get average out,
but it gets amplified. And
there was a later paper called DQN,
sorry, double DQN that fixes this
by using a very simple insight that the
bias comes from using the same network
to both pick the best value sorry, the
best action and evaluate it. And so,
then their idea was to decouple them
using the online network to select the
target network um
um to
select and then the target network to
evaluate. So, you keep the same two
networks from DQN, but you just like
rewrote them.
um
Okay.
Now,
um
DQN works
very beautifully for discrete action
spaces.
But in robotics, we are usually because
our robot
manipulators and so on are continuous,
we are interested in continuous action
spaces, right? Um so, this kind of now
is kind of like a fundamental challenge
of how do you apply this in robotics?
um
because, you know, with this uh
with with the arc max over there, we we
cannot like enumerate like an infinite
action space.
Uh so,
uh because there is no closed-form
solution for this kind of continuous
optimization problem, there are like
three different ways uh
that we will very briefly discuss how we
can solve them.
Um the first one is discretization. So,
we can
chop the continuous action action space
into a discrete grid and apply DQN
directly. Um this is very simple, but um
it's exponentially costly in in the
dimensions. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So, uh like with a 7° of freedom arm,
even with a coarse discretization per
joint like this will explode
combinatorially.
The second one is sampling. So, we could
like also um
do like Monte Carlo uh sampling, draw
like N candidate actions, and evaluate
uh the Q function for each of the
actions, and return kind of the best.
And the third one is um to learn the
argmax with a second neural network. Um
that's going to be a DDPG. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so, instead of solving the optimization
at test time, we try to
uh move this into the training.
Um so, each approach is kind of
different, but um it tries to answer the
same question. Like, uh how do you find
the the peak of a uh
complex [clears throat] non-linear
function over a continuous space. And
so, the right choice also depends a
little bit on on your specific action
uh dimensionality and setup and so on.
Um
Okay, so here uh I will Here is one
example for um spatial discretization,
which is kind of quite smart, as it
side-steps this um
combinational
uh explosion problem.
Uh where for uh pick and place um
in this paper, they um exploited um the
geometric structure of the problem
um by mapping um
the actions to um to the 2D top-down uh
observations of the camera
um so that instead of a a separate
action head, they use a fully
convolutional neural network that takes
kind of like a height map, so with RGBD
um
as input, and outputs a dense Q uh value
map, so one Q value per pixel
uh per rotation angle, and then evaluate
this at 16 discrete orientations.
Um so, the argmax is over the the map.
Uh
And here is
an example. This is working. Yeah. Uh
here is the system in action. Um The
cool thing is that it doesn't like learn
to reach uh just or to grasp
immediately. It uh actually first pushes
objects that are cluttered uh to
rearrange them into more um graspable
configurations and only then attempts to
grasp. So, it first singulates and then
grasps.
And um this pushing before uh grasping
strategy was never programmed. Uh nobody
told the robot that pushing is useful.
So, it kind of discovered this entirely
on its own purely from maximizing um the
the the reward signal.
And um so and this emerges through this
Bellman backup where the Q function
um for grasping assigns low value to
cluttered configurations because
grasping is uh uh the grasping success
is low there.
Okay. So, spatial discretization works
nice or beautifully when the action
space uh
has uh exploitable geometric structure.
But what about the general case uh that
we care more about when
uh we have like let's say a 7° of
freedom uh robot arm with like some
joint configuration. Um the simplest
approach is to use Monte Carlo sampling,
right? So, we sample an actions
uniformly from the action space, uh
evaluate Q for each, and then return the
best.
Um and this works because um the Q
uh
Q of pi is a is a smooth neural network
function of A. And if we uh sample
densely enough, uh we'll always find
something close to the true arcmax.
Um but
the
uh so although it it kind of works
because it's smooth as we said, it
requires N forward passes per action
selection. It doesn't really scale. And
then also like the
the quality depends entirely on on the
number of samples and on luck. So, there
is no guarantee of of finding like the
the right arc max.
The cross entropy method is a smarter
version of the Monte Carlo sampling. So,
instead of sampling blindly from the
entire action space, we iteratively
concentrate samples around the high Q
values.
So, the algorithm is is pretty simple.
We We again sample some actions from a
Gaussian. We then keep the some number
of elite actions with the highest Q,
refit the Gaussian to those,
repeat
a bunch of times and then return.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> It And this works very very beautifully.
It has kind of two limitations. One that
it's unimodal.
So, if it's
you know, if like it has if
it will kind of like
find the the peak that you know, you
sample closest to. It's not like a
guarantee for the true arc max.
And then the optimization cost is paid
at test time. So, you have to like do
like
N times K forward passes at every single
control step. Right? So, it it really um
needs like a lot of time or it can take
a a long time
during optimization at test time.
Um
Here is a application of this
this paper called QT opt.
This was from Google
and and Berkeley.
This is a demonstration of exactly this
algorithm
for robotics in a robotics farm.
I think they had like around seven
cookers or so from 2018.
>> [clears throat]
>> And here kind of they they made this
work for the first time
by using Q-learning with the
cross-entropy method and a huge replay
buffer
K real grasps a lot from all these
different robots allowing each
expensive very expensive real world
transition to contribute to to many
gradient updates.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay.
So
up until now we've been using now this
this kind of cross-entropy method,
right? to to solve the arc max problem
every time the robot needs to move. But
we as we said like we have this n times
K forward pass at test time this is just
like kind of inefficient. Right?
Especially like for high frequency
control. Now
the third kind of like solution to this
problem is DDPG. So deep deterministic
policy gradients
that
tries to learn the arc max instead of
instead of searching for it.
So the idea is instead of sampling we
we're going to introduce a second
network called the actor whose entire
job is to predict
directly predict the action that
maximizes the Q function.
So now at test time we have collapsed
this expensive iterative search into a
single forward pass.
And so now we have kind of these two
networks the critic which is the
standard Q network like we saw in DQN.
It's still being trained with the TD
loss
to estimate [clears throat] the value of
state action pairs. And then we have the
actor which is the new part. Uh we train
this specifically to output actions um
that the critic says have a high value.
Uh so, it takes a state and directly
outputs a uh continuous action.
Um technically, we train like how we
train the actor puts us in in policy
gradient territory.
Uh we will cover probably this in the
next lecture, so I will not go um too
much into the details for now. Think of
this is just like the actor is trying to
maximize the Q uh value and gradient
descent does does the rest.
Um
Yes, maybe two
small things uh before we finish
um
about how we uh update the actor. Um
so, we ask the critic in which direction
the action space increases uh the Q
values, and then we move the actor's
parameter in that direction. Um
Mathematically, we do this by applying
the chain rule uh to the expected return
um by taking the gradient of the Q
function with respect uh to the action,
um and then evaluated at the current
actor's output and
>> [clears throat]
>> uh multiplied by the gradient of the
actor with respect to its weights.
And then, maybe like one small uh issue
is the exploration. So, with DQN, uh we
had discrete action uh spaces, but here
our uh
action space is now continuous, right?
And so, we can't do this uh greedy like
uh
uh like with some probability we pick a
random action. Like that would be
actually bad because we could thrash our
robot if we sample like random joint
configurations. Uh so, instead of doing
that in DDPG, uh we do uh what it does
is uh it adds a Gaussian noise directly
to the actor's output at training time.
Um so, you take whatever action it
recommends and then perturb it a little
bit with a
uh slightly Gaussian noise to give you
like smooth local exploration about the
current actors policy.
Um
All right. So, here is uh
how it looks like. Uh there are also
some applications for real robots of
DDPG.
Um it uh works now with high-dimensional
observation outputs and continuous
actions. We don't need cross-entropy
method at test time.
Um maybe like one one thing to note note
is that it's a notoriously brittle
algorithm.
Uh it's very sensitive to hyper
parameters and doesn't always converge.
And as I said, this this noise parameter
uh needs to be tuned manually and for
each new environment. And so, if you
pick it like uh too small, like you
might not explore enough.
And if you do a too large noise, then
it's unstable.
All right. To
uh recap, um
here is kind of like a taxonomy on some
trade-offs of the methods uh we worked
we we discussed today.
Um so, starting from the left, we have
the exact methods um that are kind of
clean and gives you like convergence
guarantees, but are restricted to uh
having known dynamics model and working
only on kind of like tabular
environments or very small state space
environments. Um then
we've moved to um Q-learning and SARSA
um
to um
uh
learning from experience uh rather from
uh a known model.
Um and we get convergence guarantees as
long as we explore long enough.
Um but we are still kind of stuck in in
kind of small uh
toy environments. And then
uh at the end then we move to this deep
RL with discrete actions like DQN and
and double DQN. This is where things get
start getting interesting
uh where we um,
have like our first neural networks, we
can encode image observations.
Um, we get a replay buffer and so forth.
Um, but of course we have now no, uh,
guarantees for convergence anymore.
And we are still stuck with, uh,
discrete action spaces. And then finally
we've covered
deep RL with continuous actions,
uh, with DDPG, QT-Opt, um, and cross
entropy methods, which can now, uh, kind
of handle continuous actions, high
dimensional state spaces, um, and we are
still off-policy, uh, with a replay
buffer.
Uh, with this, uh, thank you for
attention,
um, and, uh, yeah, let's move on to the
papers.
>> [applause]